and and I believe that we do have our
expert with us on murmurs ax is a
coordinator of the national cave rescue
commission he has more than 30 years of
experience in cave rescues and he's
joining us from Bloomington Indiana
thank you so much on Mar for coming on
with us this is just an incredible
rescue story but clearly it's not over
yet because the boys aren't out you said
this is one of the most difficult
rescues that you've come across thus far
explain what the rescuers are going to
have to do now to get these boys out
well of course initially we were looking
at three primary options of getting them
out that the diving option which has
been discussed the waiting for the water
to go down for a lull in the rain to
allow them to pump it down enough for
them to get out on their own and then
there was the potential for putting
another entrance in either by drilling
or by finding and exploiting a natural
entrance it looks like that that last
option is becoming less and less of an
option and they're focusing more on the
first two so at this point they're the
it's really up to what the weather does
to see what the best option is going to
be Anwar when we talk about this dive I
think for folks who don't know it is a
treacherous dive even for seasoned
divers is it not absolutely cave divers
people who specialized in diving in
enclosed and overhead environments
trained for hundreds and hundreds of
hours to be able to do it it's a very
easy thing to start to do the problem is
is that it's a very difficult thing to
to plan for and be ready for all the
contingencies and the problem becomes is
that the contingencies are what could
potentially be fatal panicking losing
your mask having an issue with the
equipment in an environment where you're
enclosed is is incredibly dangerous so
you're talking about training
potentially a dozen kids here to dive
their way out of this cave how
challenging is that how long would that
take well it that's going to depend on
the exigencies of the moment if they
have the time then they can take as much
time as they need until the people who
are training them feel that they are
ready if
the the flooding situation worsens to
the point where they decide that they
need to try to do something then there
you have to weigh the risk versus the
potential benefit there and regardless
of which option is used whether it's a
diving or waiting for the water to go
down there are risks involved so it's
not a there are no good choices talk
about the risks of keeping the boys
there for potentially four more months
as the regional governor suggested they
may have to do the the primary risk is
the risk of enough rain and or a failure
of the pumping system enough to allow
the area that they're in which is
currently safe to become flooded and for
them not to have a safe zone in the cave
that is that's the biggest immediate
risk the other long-term risks of course
are the issues that they may have
medical issues they may have
psychological issues those those are
more manageable and they don't affect
the group as a whole in general and at
least they'll be getting food and
medical supplies as well from the
pictures we've seen they they appear to
be in good spirits so that is important
on marmar so thank you so much for
joining us you're welcome